endet was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ich
hoffe natürlich euch jedes gut ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen ich habe keine ahnung
welches videos zuerst kommt entweder das
hier oder das tue ich das ganze hotel
test auf jeden fall bin ich gerade im
adlon kempinski adlon kempinski hotel in
berlin das atmen also kennt man halt nur
unter adlon wirklich ein geistes kann
das hotel also mit abstand das häufigste
hotel in dem ich hier war hat auch
seinen preis aber ich dachte mir wenn
ich jetzt schon mal hier bin dann muss
ich auch auf jeden fall viele haben
schon gedacht als ich habe einige news
über gesehen die diesen döner schon
probiert haben die waren aber alle unten
im restaurant und ich bin halt jetzt
auch ein zimmer und kann ihn aus zu
bestellen deswegen dachte ich mir kommt
machen wir mal das geil hier ist man
kann rund um die uhr zimmerservice
anrufen die bringen wir alles was du
willst wirklich alles also das klingt ja
vielleicht fast ein bisschen ironisch
gesagt alles aber die bringen die
wirklich alles die fahr los und besorgen
es dir zur not ich würde ich auch
niemals pen wenn ich kein video drehen
würde aber checkt auf jeden fall auch
das video zum ganzen erdteil dann ab wir
setzen uns jetzt erst mal hierhin und
bestellen hoffe das klappt das hier ist
die speisekarte also hier das kannst du
alles aufs zimmer bestellen hier kann
man auch frühstück bestellen zum
beispiel gibt es ja einen frisch
gepressten saft gerade mal zwölf euro 50
und aber auch hauptgerichte wir zum
beispiel rinderfilet streifen hier gibt
es auch ein wiener schnitzel suppen
pasta also alles und alles halt auch
natürlich sehr sehr teuer das problem
ist denn döner gibt es nicht im
hauptrestaurant sondern nur in der bar
also in der art von bar oder so keine
ahnung so wie übrigens für meine frisur
ich war gerade auch schwimmen wie gesagt
alles so fürs video sonst will ich dass
ich machen aber ich hoffe ich kann den
döner auch über einen service bestellt
ich zeige euch mal eben hier wo ich den
gefunden habe hier bin ich jetzt auf der
andern seite lobby lounge mit bar und
wenn man jetzt hier runter scrollen
kann man hieraus menü klicken und dann
kommt hier irgendwo warte ich habe es
eben schon gefunden hier adlon classics
adlon döner kebab kalbsrücken streifen
trüffel creme mariniertes kraut rote
zwiebeln tomaten flammen wurde für 26
euro eigentlich dachte ich das teil
kostet 19 euro aber anscheinend ist
weiß ich nicht dann versuche ich jetzt
mal mein glück ich hoffe zimmerservice
da müssen wir angerufen ja
was ist mit diesem telefonat kaputt ach
da gibt es zum glück noch
dieses telefon hat einen schaden also
ohne scheiß wie viele telefone haben
hier ein zwei drei telefone ja warum
auch nicht ja hallo hier ist es möglich
auch den döner kebab aufs zimmer zu
bekommen ja dann hätte ich gern einmal
das wäre es auch schon ja super perfekt
kein stress danke bis gleich toto kein
problem natürlich mehr denken können
dass kein problem ist hier also der
service hier ist wirklich geisteskrank
die machen alles chef meint der 25
minuten warten gar kein problem wir
bringen super und bevor ich es vergesse
eine sache muss ich dazu noch sagen weil
ganz ganz viele youtuber meinten so l
der döner schmeckt nicht oder 11 19 euro
das werk so ich bin echt gespannt was
ich gleich sage aber ein kumpel von mir
der hat sich mal gearbeitet und der
meinte dass der döner eigentlich schon
nice ist das ist nur auf das problem ist
dass da jemand ist ja die nicht richtig
zubereitet und das kommt halt drauf an
was gerade in der küche ist deswegen
hoffe ich mal gerade jemand in der küche
der plan von döner hat und nicht nur von
zwei sterne restaurants wie man da
lecker ist macht und ein von döner kebab
für 26 euro ja ich weiss dazu sagen soll
[Musik]
so leute es ankommen oder halt mein
döner ja so wird natürlich standardgemäß
dünner hier im art servierten also
wirklich okay jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
sieht aus wie ein burger das ist doch
ist das ein döner gut also ja schöner
halt irgendwie ne also da muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen das habe ich mir irgendwie
anders vorgestellt vor allem das brot
kann man das kann ich einfach hier sind
ja
also das sind doch burger band safe
ja bei allen wir uns mal schnell bevor
es kalt wird hier habe ich jetzt mein
döner wirklich leute schaut euch das mal
an jeden hier nicht so ganz ich habe ja
das gefühl dass die einfach kein
fladenbrot mehr hatten und deswegen
einfach diese bürger brötchen genommen
haben die soll ich denen essen also das
sieht lecker aus aber wir sollten da er
hey wie sollte reinbeißen so was trinkt
man zum löhner natürlich eine coke oder
iran aber habe ich nicht also oder was
heißt ich mich hier haben wir nicht sagt
ich muss das eigentlich mit messer und
gabel essen ja ich würde es wirklich
gern so essen wie ein döner deswegen
hatte ich den mal hier rein
26 euro es sich
ok also wir haben hier drauf trüffel
mario habe ich euch heute lesen tomate
dann kalbsrücken streifen und ich hoffe
ich bin jetzt einfach mal gespannt
plätzen
und sogar nicht nur trüffel
ach so wir haben sogar nicht nur trüffel
mario sondern auch richtigen trüffel
also diese trüffel scheiben weiß man
dass so nennt muss nochmal rein meisten
aber an sich ne
nase schon voll mit kumpel mario keine
ahnung warum wir hier catcher
mitgeliefert wird ketchup und
mayo also sehr auf dem dinner ketchup
haben möchte läuft ihrem leben vorbei
wobei einer fun fact als ich so 12 war
und meinen ersten döner gegessen habe
hab ich denn nur mit fleisch und ketchup
gewissen haye wenn ich da jetzt darüber
nachdenken
man muss eben gesagt ein bisschen so
rein drücken also meine erste meinung
dazu es ist schon sehr sehr lecker es
ist super lecker also merkt schon geil
der einzige punkt wo ich meckere muss
inhalt die bürger bands es schmeckt
waren sich schon sowie fladenbrot aber
ist es nicht mehr also das brot könnte
auf jeden fall besser sein ich weiß gar
nicht ob das standard ist dass die
wirklich dass in diesem brötchen liefern
aber das kann ich eigentlich fast nicht
vorstellen auf der krautsalat
superlecker
leute ich würde eigentlich als erst mal
eben auf und werde euch noch ein
feedback es ist wirklich gut also meine
meinung ist sonja man vergisst schnell
dass das 26 euro partner also jeder bis
zwei euro
leute ich hab auch vergessen muss sagen
jetzt bin ich auch wirklich satt also
sting hat mich sehr viel sagt gemacht
man muss natürlich sagen für 26 euro ist
das natürlich schon extrem extrem teuer
aber wir sind hier noch mal auch in
einem fünf sterne superior hotel wo
alles ziemlich teuer ist und an sich mit
einem klassischen traditionellen döner
so will man ihn bestimmt hier auch 200
meter weiter um die ecke 53 bekommt hat
das ja nix zu tun also so merkt schon
dass die zutaten hier eine 10 von 10
also wirklich auch das fleisch und so
war schon super super lecker wir hatten
noch diese trüffel scheiben drauf hier
könnt ihr das sehen guck mal hier ja
trüffel ich mein wenn du zum guten
italiener gehst oder einen trüffel pasta
ist bezahlst du auch deine 19 euro dafür
deswegen muss ich sagen und wir hatten
noch jede menge fleisch wenn der dollar
jetzt so wie bei den ganzen anderen
youtube die den getestet haben 19 euro
kostete ohne scheiß ich hatte gar nichts
auszusetzen gehabt wirklich kann man
bezahlen dafür ich meine brust trüffel
drauf ich weiß nicht vielleicht war
damals bei denen ich hab so dass das
video was ich gesehen habe das habe ich
mir gestern am rhein gezogen von papa
platz er hat 19 euro bezahlt ist aber
auch schon naher oder so vielleicht war
da noch keinen trüffel drauf ich weiß es
nicht genau also 26 euro ist natürlich
schon eine hausnummer und würde ich
jetzt so einfach so mir das mal zu
können niemals dafür bezahlen also das
ist einfach zu viel dann was ich mich
gerade auch gefragt hab eigentlich hätte
ich ja dem chef der mir das hier
gebracht hat also dem ja wie nennt man
die leute den portier zucker trinkgeld
geben müssen oder muss man das also ich
weiß ich bin ja nie in solchen hotels
erwarten die das dann dass man auch noch
dringender gibt selbst wenn der dinner
show 26 euro kostet wahrscheinlich nicht
mehr naja weiß ich nicht genau wie ihr
könnt aber in die kommentare schreiben
ansonsten leute ich nehme euch mal kurz
noch mit ins bad ich habe mir gerade ein
bad eingelassen da gehe ich als nur ein
checkt auf jeden fall dann auch das
video zu dem ganzen hotel also wirklich
das lohnt sich für mich war es auf jeden
fall den erfahrung heute über den winter
zu essen und wenn ihr mal in der nähe
seid die gelegenheit habe bestellte mal
also ich finde man macht nichts falsch
man bezahlt zwar einmal viel aber es
lohnt sich so ein bisschen schon vom
geschmackserlebnis her würde ich dem
döner 12 9 pluspunkte geben von zehn
wahrscheinlich hatte ich glück dass da
jemand war denn auch gut machen konnte
so wie mein kollege gesagt hat wenn man
den preis mit betrachtet schwierig aber
ich meine wenn er sonst denkt ist und da
war wirklich viel fleisch drauf dann
zahlst du auch mal schnell 28 deswegen
an sich in ordnung einige von euch haben
ja vielleicht schon mal gegessen
beschreibt gerne eure farm in die
kommentare und ja danke fürs zuschauen
leute lasst doch nach oben da abonniert
den kanal für mehr essen des videos ich
bin auf jeden fall die nächste zeit ein
bisschen unterwegs in deutschland und
teste mal das ein oder andere coole
hotel-restaurant was weiß ich habe drei
leute